hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will ich möchte heute was ganz
leckeres machen sich mein gut ich mache
eigentlich was leckeres aber heute ist
richtig lecker denn heute gibt es käse
kuchen muffins ohne boden mit feigen und
minze und es ist richtig lecker ich
hatte dir mal irgendwann gepostet und
irgendwann als ich mal meinen käsekuchen
rezept gemacht habe habe ich auch gesagt
dass ich eins ohne boden habe und es ist
eben das hier
ich verarbeite ich verarbeite den teig
jetzt allerdings alles käse kuchen
muffins
aber man kann es auch einfach so als
kuchen machen ich sage ich einfach mal
kurz die zutaten und zwar brauche ich
100 gramm butter 100 gramm zucker ein
bisschen vanille extrakt drei eier die
habe ich getrennt in eigelb und eiweiß
zwei esslöffel christa könnten
hartweizen oder weizen kriegs nehmen
500 gramm magerquark und in halben
teelöffel backpulver und ich habe noch
eine limette und eine zitrone
beides natürlich bio damit ich die
schale verwenden kann und später brauche
ich dann noch ein bisschen honig ein
paar feigen und die minze die habe ich
jetzt noch hinten stehen die er mich
vergessen herr zu räumen
ich werde jetzt damit starten und geht
jetzt erst mal meine mutter in einer
rührschüssel die sollte schön weich sein
und wenn ihr mal vergesst die butter
rechtzeitig raus zu stellen können dass
er einfach mit so einer reibe fein
reiben
dann wird es auch ganz schnell
zimmermann das hab ich das nämlich
gestern gemacht die mikro oder in der
mikrowelle aber geheim hat keine leute
haben wir keine mikrowelle weiter aber
vielleicht wieder einmal so passen
kuchen machen
jetzt gehen wir noch den zucker mit dazu
und lass es einfach mal verrühren und
ich nutze die zeit aber auch schon mal
um einfach mal ein eiweiß zu schlagen
kann jetzt natürlich auch in so einer
schüssel machen und das ganze dann
tauschen
aber so bin ich dann gleichzeitig fertig
beide töchter stufe
zum einen habe ich übrigens noch eine
prise salz mit dazu gegeben dann geht
das ganze nämlich bisschen schneller
jetzt nehme ich hier meine vanilleschote
und gebt da einfach ein paar tropfen mit
dazu
da braucht man immer ganz wenig nur und
dann kommt auch direktes eigelb mit rein
und dann lasse ich einfach nochmal etwa
drei minuten verrühren
dass das ganze eben so richtig schön
cremig
netzwerke ich hier mein backpulver mit
dem gries damit gleich nicht so klumpp
und je nachdem ob ihr zwei kreuzen oder
hartweizengrieß habt bei weitem gries
wird das ganze etwas feiner unter
hartweizengrieß ritzebüttel ja so gesagt
nee nee das anhalter kleine fraglichen
drin von dem krieg ich glaube ich mag
keinen krieg mit der grießbrei gibt es
doch mehr krieg praktisch gar nicht wo
du magst nix was reich und etwas heiß
und was psychisch geht jetzt hier den
magerquark mit der butter mischung
ankommt da der kreis mit dazu und dann
reibe ich noch ein bisschen
limettenschale mit rein mag ich ganz
gerne einfach für das frische aroma das
riecht so gut
das geht natürlich nur mit bio geht
natürlich nur mit bio sonst ein paar
stoff vermitteln
und weil wir noch ein bisschen zitrone
ihr könnt übrigens wenn ihr mal bio
zitrone und bio limiten daheim habt aber
die schale karte missbraucht könnt ihr
einfach abreiben und einfrieren dann
hatte die nämlich immer da aber ihr
verschwindet die schal einfach in
deutscher sprache zu tun stoffe mal die
schale in die spülmaschine
ja es geht auch das heißt man kann die
zu 100 prozent benutzen jetzt schneide
ich mir die zitrone auf und geht noch
ein paar spritzer zitronensaft mit dazu
karten telefon oder einen teelöffel
berühre ich das noch ganz kurz
nicht auf höchster stufe er auf
mittlerer stufe
jetzt hab ich da einfach nur noch den
eischnee unter so wird das ganze richtig
schön luftig und locker und der krise
sorgt in den in der käsekuchen masse
einfach für die bindung damit die
einfach nicht auseinanderbrechen
ich wundere mich immer darüber rasch das
ja eigentlich gelernte bäcker oder oder
küchen oder wie auch immer
woher du bist einfach nur logisch
mainz von chennai und quark wird zwar
auch heber warum hat mal so dass
investoren und dann der rest habe
einfach nachlesen
maria und ich besprühen der zwischenzeit
meine mappe backform mit etwas back
trend spray kann man natürlich auch
einfach etwas butter nehmen und das
ganze aus finden
das problem ist immer nationale pinsel
was putzen muss sonst insel wenn wir
keine spülmaschine gehen aus silikon
ach so da stimmt war ich denke immer an
die winkel an die havel
dies ist möglich jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach noch ein bisschen fries und
bestreut damit die formel
tomasz ist jetzt einfach damit später
leichter rauskommt dass bei allen muffin
formen machen oder machen bin ja also
man brauche halt unbedingt ne antihaft
muffin formen weil ansonsten die
käsekuchen machen uns auf keinen fall
raus jetzt nehme ich einfach einen
löffel und gibt diese käsekuchen masse
in die muffin förmchen rein so einen
großen gehäufter esslöffel
ich habe dir jetzt ziemlich voll gemacht
ein bisschen teig habe ich jetzt noch da
muss ich dann später ihnen eben eine
form noch erfüllen und so gebe ich die
käse kuchen muffins jetzt bei 175 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen
die brauchen so ungefähr 15 bis 20
minuten die stäbchen probe kann man auch
hier machen und dann sage ich einfach
gleich und wird aber in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die feige verarbeiten
ich bereite schon mal meine feigen so
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier sieben
zeigen
ich benutze aber noch 6 1 1 durch dann
später mit dass du und die habe ich
jetzt bereits gewaschen und nehmen jetzt
einfach da oben diesen stengel ab und
unten auch hier den ansatz und halbiert
die es einfach mal die besten fein
kommen übrigens aus der türkei seien
stadt auch wieder das sagen dann alle
tiere aber das ist jetzt keine typischen
folgen
ich habe leider nur brasilianische
gefunden jetzt schneide ich dir einfach
in so kleine er was ihn an dass ich
drittel für einfach ich finde es mir
sagt die besten feigen pro stück bis es
kommt auch spanien oder wer hat es
erfunden ist immer blöd sind also ich
bin einfach es können auch super feigen
aus aus aus brasilien kommen oder aber
dass ich mag mich aber nichts gebracht
celia hat wieder freigekommen
trotz der master kag und depeche der
kartoffel auf deutschland schaffen aus
holz
ich finde es eine diskussion immer
gesagt wer hat was erfunden der die
türken haben es erfunden
die österreicher haben hauptsache es
schmeckt strecke muss her kommen wie das
erfunden hat ich finde das kann man
nicht genau sagen woher war es
heutzutage nicht alles hier für mich
man kann übrigens die fragen auch
schälen aber ich nehme dir ganz kann
einfach mit der haut mit der schale
außen rum
mein papa hat mir gezeigt dass man die
mit essen kann ich es auch wirklich es
ist nicht möglich stehen sie immer ob
ich den fehler diese es wenn ich mal
keine zeit hat dann lässt sich auf die
schale mit mäßiger baum geklaut haben
oder so dann hast du keine zeit zum
schälen der türkei schmeckt es gut
formbar sind die richtig tolle türkei
wachsen sie über all das ist hierfür
eine 49 cent auf 79 cent
die folgen für andere ich geb dir jetzt
hier in unschädlichen rein denn ich
werde jetzt gleich noch marinieren und
der feigen geschmack kommt ganz gut oder
ganz besonders thema da noch wissen die
männer mit dazu gibt ich nehme jetzt
noch ein bisserl von der schale und dann
nehme ich auch limettensaft und wenn du
fragt woher ich das weiß das habe ich
heute im fokus gelesen dass stand
nämlich auf dem schild neben der folge
aber ich hatte ihn mir das sowieso
wir haben 79 cent frage des haupttäters
schwaben schon um ja nicht wo es anders
nicht was günstiger
doch kann man auch nehmen also man kann
zum beispiel auch orangen nehmen oder im
sommer würde ich sitze mit erdbeeren
machen also zb saison kann man einfach
irgendwas anderes nehmen wissenschaft
und dann gebe ich für die süße noch ein
bisschen honig mit dazu und natürlich
auch fürs aroma ich habe da einfach so
eine blöde honig gibt da einfach
ungefähr 1 2 esslöffel mit dazu je
nachdem wie sie das handhaben wollen
und als ganz besondere frische und
leckeres aroma nehme ich noch ein paar
minzblättern die passen dann nämlich
auch super dazu eine ganz blöde frage
ich blütenhonig eigentlich egal
und jetzt kurator von bienen auch wenn's
von blüten kommt jetzt glaub ich da
einmal drauf mal kommen nämlich die
aromen richtig gut raus und den recht
zügig einfach klein die ätherischen öle
wohl ich sage
ponitz verrichtet einfach und lasst es
dann so lange stehen bis die käsekuchen
machen und aus dem ofen rauskommen dann
können es sich hier nämlich die aromen
so ein bisschen verbinden das ganze kann
durchziehen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich eigentlich schon zum servieren
wieder fand richtig schnelles und
einfaches rezept geld
meine käse kuchen muffins habe ich
vorhin auf ein abgestürzt und das ist so
im ofen gehen sie ziemlich auf und dann
fallen sie noch mal ein bisschen
zusammen
ihr könnt es verhindern indem ihr sieben
abgeschalteten ofen noch ein bisschen
auskühlen lassen
aber ich finde es auch so nicht schlimm
denn hat das schmecken gut
jetzt nehme ich sie mir einfach so wie
sie sind ihr könnt jetzt einmal umdrehen
oder so lassen ich was jetzt so und so
wie sie jetzt auf einem teller
da kommt nämlich jetzt darum diese
feigen mit dazu
und dann gern auch wissen von diesem von
der flüssigkeit heraus gekommen ist
wer sucht apropos in hollywood ich habe
jetzt gerade guckt bienenhonig ist nicht
vegan und zwar ich wusste auch nicht
dass wie honig erwin kurze ist keine
gedanken aber wirklich und zwar volle es
in meiner kindheit also nur aber woher
nur arbeiten musste haben wir im
kindergarten honig aus löwenzahn gemacht
das weiß ich noch der schmeckt richtig
lecker dass staaten wie kanada und ist
ein veganer dass ich kann mich auch
nicht erinnern muss man nachschauen
vielleicht haben wir mal mit honig
machen aus löwenzahn wenn die coole idee
weil die bienen wie gesagt dass es sich
vegan die werden ausgebeutet müssen
empfehlen b movie gesehen
das sieht man das doch da komme die doch
eng auf die also da kommst du doch dann
drauf schauen sie hin werde man die tür
menschen und arbeiten ohne tariflohn von
tage sprache morgens bis abends
deswegen ist mir geht kein mindestlohn
da gibt's keinen mindestlohn bei der ich
habe jetzt hier hast du das echt erwähnt
aber man könne erst mal gucken
vielleicht kammer zum löwenzahn holen
aber auch der schmeckt wirklich lecker
ich kann mich noch aus dem kindergarten
erinnern ich mich doch anna massagen
kindergarten erinnern kann man im
kindergarten schmeckt anders
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
honig drüber gegeben und jetzt nehme ich
wieder so ein bisschen puderzucker das
ist jetzt wieder mein süßer schnee
schmilzt nämlich mit dem ich über das
käse küchen tv halle
den kriegst du jetzt nicht dass ich
jetzt mein teller fürs foto sich immer
so thoma ich mache jetzt anstellen und
den dachstuhl ein problem aber das
kennen wir schon viele männer dieses
leiden müssen wenn die frauen das um die
posten müssen
im sommer würde ich den käsekuchen
übrigens vorher erst in den kühlschrank
stellen das war richtig schön kalt ist
und dann einfach servieren ich finde
dann schmeckt er noch besser zusammen
mit dem mit den fein druck aber ich mag
den wien oli nicht drauf haben ich mag
das ohne honig becker nein aber es tut
mir die bereit ist die arminen leid die
ohne also ich find das die feigen mit
der minister richtig gute zu passen weil
es ergänzt sich einfach alles so aber
wie gesagt kann man auch was anderes
nehmen als frei und ohne witz
ich denke jetzt ein bissel weiter
fertigessen lösung angeber sowieso den
angeber gestik kommt und nach unten
sieht aus wie bei einem fünf sterne koch
und vor allen dingen ist man fertig in
ungefähr 45 minuten also länger habe ich
jetzt nicht gebraucht im prinzip war die
backzeit es längst mit der minze schmidt
wies wahnsinn
also mit minister seinen prothesen oder
etwa mini-jobs geht auch und ich denke
das hier ist noch fertig ihr dürft
inzwischen schon mal das rezept
nachlesen of sales blog.de und wir sehen
uns dann schon ganz bald wieder mit
einem anderen leckeren rezepten